[Music]
the book was originally written
primarily in my mind for the guys that
were portrayed in it
I wrote the book I wanted you know I had
been with this team won Bravo second
platoon we went through you know from
Kuwait to Baghdad and I got very close
to those guys as a journalist but I also
later became close to them as a person
you know a different level and as I that
started to happen when I was writing the
book I was like what's gonna make these
guys laugh like the fact that I can that
I'm gonna render all these things that
they said that they probably even forgot
that they talked about and and all of
their complaints and the humor that
that's going to be really cool of course
I had to put in things that made them
very uncomfortable too but part of it
was just to let them know that that
their story was out there the transition
to the screen has taken five years I
went to HBO after I'd written my
three-part Rolling Stone series I think
the last article ran in July 2003 the
war was new I wrote a book proposal and
got a contract with Putnam to write a
book at the same time I went to HBO and
I said hey we should do a miniseries and
or I said you should do a miniseries you
can have the rights to my book and I
will I will not write it I don't want to
be involved it's yours and they took it
and they they gave me a Option fee which
is actually not a big deal in Hollywood
and they spent a year with it and really
did nothing and after that time HBO came
back to me and they said there's a guy
in Baltimore named David Simon he works
with Edie burns his partner and they do
a show called The Wire I had never seen
the wire I was in Afghanistan when the
wire came out
kind of missed it and I but I sat down I
watched the first two seasons one
weekend and I thought what an amazing
show and so I flew out to Baltimore I
met with David and he said I I like your
book HBO has it I work with HBO I would
like to adapt this into a miniseries but
the one catches I don't want to do it
without you and so on the one hand Simon
gave me a tremendous opportunity because
he became a mentor as a screenwriter I
worked as a screenwriter with him and
Eddie but on the other hand I never
wanted to be involved so it was a huge
pain in the ass so I always you know
what I like to do with the Simon & burns
is acknowledge the great thing that they
did by by bringing me in and sort of
making me into a screenwriter and then I
like to complain bitterly about it
that's just how I am it is strange and
as a journalist my journalism has always
been about not having the journalists in
the in the story and so I actually
didn't want to have a character
portraying me in the miniseries it was
David Simon who pointed out if we're
actually adapting your book you were in
that Humvee and we're not going to adapt
the story and have an empty seat or put
a fictitious marine in that seat we have
to put you there what I was happy with
is that we wrote my character so that
he's he's there and you see how this
story was acquired but he's not the
focus of the show
my goal in covering the military has
always been to demystify it in a sense
and I always felt that prior to the war
on terrorism as its called
or the war on terror prior to that our
country was going through this massive
sort of reconnect with the greatest
generation and you had all these movies
and books where they were just
celebrating the guys who fought World
War two and which is fine we should
celebrate those guys but I think with
that mist it's sort of because the
people who were behind the celebration
of the Greatest Generation were people
who generally hadn't fought in wars and
had no experience with war they came at
it from this sort of misty-eyed
like oh my gosh these these giants
fought World War two they were fighting
a good war the country came together
what a wonderful special time in
American history all true but I read
Greatest Generation writers who actually
fought in World War two such as Norman
Mailer Joseph Heller Kurt Vonnegut even
Gaurav at all and they they're writing
on war was never about how glorious and
wonderful their writing was about how it
was dirty morally ambiguous and often
just filled with horrors so when I got
to Iraq it was interesting I just wanted
to I didn't want to write about these
guys as heroes or as villains and the
upshot is after Episode one of
Generation Kill aired there were a lot
of bloggers and reviewers who said a lot
of people got it but there are a lot of
people who said oh my god these guys
they their talk sounds racist
it sounds homophobic they talk about
killing like they want to kill and they
were horrified and and I think people
were shocked that people in the Marine
Corps today don't talk like Tom Hanks in
like a World War two movie you know and
the the the truth is Marines who are 22
years old actually are steeped in the
same culture
as 22 year-olds who are not in the
Marines and if you look at like I was
just watching a director writer that I
really like Judd Apatow and and his like
Superbad I mean the rants that those
kids go on and super bad were the
talking it's very misogynistic it's it's
all about sex and in a very graphic way
and Marines talk the same way but when
it's Marines wearing the uniform people
are horrified and and I also hope that
as the series unfolds viewers will begin
to recognize that in marine culture they
have great Liberty to say things that
are horribly offensive to one another
because they have so much trust in each
other and as they move forward I think
viewers will notice that even the guy
who's been described as like a racist
cracker that his best friend is a
Mexican American and that they all
depend on each other so my intent in the
show is to try to connect people to in
an honest way to the troops that are
fighting not to glorify them and not to
demean them just show them as they are
and hopefully some viewers will get it
there were some Marines who read my book
and they're like this is great but there
was a another smaller group I like to
think that hated my book they thought at
air dirty laundry of the Marine Corps
that it was too harsh on the officers
because I portrayed there are a lot of
incompetent boobs in the little company
that I wrote about I didn't choose that
company but it I just happened to be in
an area of the battalion that had some
really dopey officers and I wrote the
book that way anyway that offended some
Marines and it is true that I went to
Camp Pendleton once to greet a marine
friend of mine who was returning from a
deployment I was with his wife and some
senior NCOs spotted me they came over
they said we don't like your book they
handcuffed me they threw me into a car
and they said you know we're gonna drive
you into the desert
they kind of realized oh my god we just
handcuffed a reporter
we can't unfortunately we can't actually
throw reporters out into the desert in
California and so they had an NP an MP
came and he has drove me off the base
and it's a huge base it was like a 20
minute drive I'm handcuffed in the back
of the car and they're driving in
silence and the MP says hey you know
kind of liked your book and I was like
that's nice and and then he says we're
driving he says hey do you have a copy
that you could maybe autograph for me
and I was like sure dude if you you know
take my handcuffs off so I did give him
one so that was one response to the book
we screamed generation kill that we
screened the first two episodes at the
Pendleton Theatre and it was an amazing
experience that we're at the home of the
first Marine Division and two two three
four hundred Marines I don't know how
many were in the theater we started
running the show and they were laughing
their asses off
they were nodding their heads it was the
best audience we've screened it for yet
because they totally got it and it was
really gratifying to me that's strange I
don't know how I don't think it changed
me let me put it this way I've done
Drive alongs in inner-city America with
LAPD cops in south-central I did okay
after I came back from Iraq the first
time I did a ride-along with some cops
in South Central LA and that night there
were several shootings a home with some
old man sleeping in it was shot up and
actually and I've seen him you know done
stories with a hospital emergency room
so the weird thing is like there's
there's plenty of horror in America to
go around to and war is obviously worse
it's on a bigger scale but didn't like
really change me that much to cover the
Iraq
or sorry to say
[Music]